dalé ma chérie ils vont faire il y aura
cinq tirs d'accord d'accord plus joffre
j'en ferai un aa retire donc ça tient
tir +1 y aura six tirs on va démarrer
par jean michel maire s'est tue tous ces
gens me sais-tu tous les six pattes en
étant situent tous les cibles mon chéri
tu fais gagner à dany le cadeau est
représenté sur les cibles et monte alors
je gagne quoi moi frères bats toi tu
gagnes le droit de rester dans
l'émission fait déjà beaucoup a dit
attention
[Musique]
tableaux statues excellent trottoirs la
lune qui gagnent des jeunes tablettes
tactiles aujourd'hui c'est bon pas ma
chérie à tokyo on va enchaîner avec
benjamin castaldi souvent ça va être
léger comment il marche à cliquer alors
potter ne baisse pas en belgique et où
ça fait mal c'est le graet mais non non
il a du mal voilà on va jouer avec
gilles verdez qui est très fort
attention alessandra et comment il se la
pète c'est un comédien pousser le ballon
quand la coupe stanley il avait les clés
voir heureusement pour l'instant tu as
toujours la tablette tactile et rami à
toi de choisir dany tu veux jouer avec
lui élie califer novelli moulin manuelle
des données bien moi tu as envie de rien
et les jours suivants mais ces faits
s'est évadé fadika ni non pas mal c'est
la gagne rien on s'était bien alors on
va jouer est ce que tu veux jouer mais
petit maintenant il ne reste plus que
deux amis mais ya moi oui mais non mais
oui mais tu as joué avec qui mes yeux
les haut-normands je peux pas il faut
adopter le bas jamais
non mais bon j'en vois déjà tiré et
kircheisen maxime kahn et d'humanisme
anna maria tués torturés lanouf et
d'accès bandana maxima gâteau sion
jamais tiré
[Rires]
ça lui allait partir valu son fou rire
ali dany c'est joli non mais si tu peux
nous parler je préfère tout me le dise
franchement je vais jamais krill tueur
at il relaté bon choix je pense voit la
passe à dix papa de blessés max 3 2 face
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à maxime et quoi qu'on fait de maxime je
dois gagner en soit génial oh c'est
génial au sujet bien que c'est ta gagne
un robot cuiseur échec
alors est ce que tu es ce que tu décides
de garder des cadeaux ou est-ce que tu
tentes en train de faire des règles en
direct non je vois ça tu te poses située
en aval de parler c'est bon alors
matches où tu vois si tu fais du combien
toi tu 44 passes ratées section où je
suis encore ses propres chaussures
attention une tablette et un rondo est
ce que tu veux que je tente le tir à à
ce que tu veux que je tente le tir
ma chérie est ce que tu fais tu vas rire
non alors je tente le tir si je mets le
tir
oui tu gagnes un voyage si je le mets
pas tu perds tout chaud si tu ne dois
pas me mettre de la balle à l'ailé
confiance en toi renchérit je danse
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
j'en peux plus du viol à jeu avec
l'envié de me faire craquer je dois être
ici
après tout par de si loin attention
attention c'est vrai ça va faire encore
mieux
attendez d'en inviter cas il va maxime
max moulis un beau tout ça mais alors on
est vraiment on peut alors aller ça
[Musique]
c'est vanessa tu viens vanessa da vient
chéri ben wallace avait 1,44 à bois
d'amont soir du combat et ça commence à
voir on est une des soeurs de talons bah
ouais ça va bien merci d'état ça va dit
vanessa
[Applaudissements]
ça va les as tu vas faire tu as quand
même une tablette un robot à
l'ordinateur que tu fais les
cartographes la serbie si j'ose dire
12 elle veut partir en voyage ce parti
en voyage et je vous ai souvent tu
touche quoi
bah je sais pas je ne vois pas que je
fais des règles qui règne mais je ne
vois pas un vandale mais c'est pas clair
là bas alors je me mets tout ouvrez la
porte
ouvrez la porte le même nom je veux
maintenant mais ouvrait la porte à la
fois on voit la paella raison je le met
alors les minutes ça c'est trop facile
pour je me mets de la rue je veux m
ouvrez la porte on voit la porte décalé
on est en direct que la fin d'année
qu'allez-vous elle sauf que moi alors je
mets pas les talons alors que je vais
pas mettre assez loin pour rien allez
mathieu tu peux m'appeler l'antenne s'il
te plaît j'ai ma plume à tout même à la
peine physiquement tu fais déjà mon
coeur alors on n'est pas là où tu es
mauvais sur la garonne
non mais qu'est ce qu'il va faire et va
très loin là également il faut rêver
merci d'en faire un martyr ok mais tu
l'as monaco
juste la rue aux quais du troisième
essai et en plus c'est une banale encore
maman troisième essai mais toi sur les
damiers la flamme solaire de balle assez
bien j'ai pas langue laquelle six écoles
mais c'est un mensonge ou alors il faut
que tu veux être plus là bas du procès
du prix là les poubelles devant rien le
nombre de matchs de foot on est chez par
une poubelle cela s'est passé est à une
fois mais ça c'est sûr ils passent oui
je tente ou pas ce que tu as toujours
espoir oui mais vie de la cades attendra
pas malheureusement dans lequel benoît
dolle mois d'août il n'est pas
réglementaire le ballon le ballon
des sirènes préparer les inventaires au
bal aura pas de palau et m'a menacée
[Applaudissements]
c'est gagné
tagada